can't believe it's the end of November
already 2023 is almost over and what a
Tre it's been speaking of which I do
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by Star
Trek Fleet command Star Trek Fleet
command is an open world MMO available
on desktop and mobile that takes place
in the vast and ever expanding Star Trek
universe recruit iconic characters from
the original series Next Generation JJ
Abrams films Discovery Kirk Spock data
Jordi is rker in there yes he is there
goes the Hol deck build iconic ships
like the USS Enterprise clling on bird
pre ramul and warberg join millions of
players Forge alliances defeat your
enemies conquer territories you forge
your own path as you boldly go when no
one has gone before the game is free and
every month new events and content are
added to the game did I mention free so
click the link below and download Star
Trek Fleet command use promo code warp
speed or scan the QR code new players
get a special starter pack their gift to
you as the game celebrates its fifth
anniversary name another time someone's
giv you a gift on their birthday that's
awesome live long and prosper and make
it so and now we talk about a new day
David Fincher film which how is a new
David Fincher film not an event movie
just kind of squeaked onto Netflix feel
like I'm in the Twilight
[Music]
Zone so the Killer is directed by David
Fincher this is also David Fincher and
screenwriter Andrew Kevin Walker the
writer of seven teaming up again for
another movie it follows a Hitman a
contract killer played by Michael fast
Bender who goes on a quest to find hunt
down and eliminate a few people for
regardless of what he would have you
think about him very personal reasons
and I got to say the first 30 minutes or
so of this movie was [__] gripping
it's such an important phase of a film's
life the first 20 or 30 minutes or so
and this movie uses every second in ways
that I can't find a flaw in the
execution it's a very personal one could
say friendly breakdown of this character
telling you the pros and cons of his job
his job being murder the Michael fast
Bender Charisma bringing it home it
climatized the audience to the
deliberate pacing that will be
throughout the film seriously if we're
just talking about opening segment of a
film and the reaction it got from me
just mentally speaking that feeling of I
might be in for something special here
call it slow call it whatever but the
killer might actually take the gold for
me in 2023 Michael fast Bender was of
course incredible Dawns on me he hasn't
made a movie since dark Phoenix I
believe dude's taking a bit of a break
but the killer shows why he was all the
talk in the 2010s it's like yeah that's
right he is that good he's perfect for
the dynamic this film's going for
because the film is all on his shoulders
I can't actually say it's Michael fast
Bender as the lead and then support
characters a b and c it's Michael fast
Bender as the lead and other characters
he runs across who will then later be
seen by Haley Joel loit I see dead
people right other folks don't always
last long in here that might be a
negative for some people maybe you want
Side characters that stick around or
characters that he can bounce off of or
have something grow with but that's not
really what the movie is it's the fast
Bender show going on a quest to take out
people people you don't really know much
about it's not like a lot of movies
where when you're watching the main
characters or in this case character
being on their Quest it still bounces
over and you get scenes from The Other
Side you get to know the Imperials in
Star Wars or the baddies and John Wick
this movie is all fast Bender he runs
across someone you haven't seen before
and will probably not see after this
scene still that said the actors who are
in these scenes with Michael fast Bender
I felt still made their Mark I saw the
movie co-star Tilda Swinton she's in a
scene but she was great cuz it is about
that dialogue that back and forth that's
the meat of this film that Michael F
Bender's character's inner monologue
which only a few short years ago I
learned there are people without an
inner monologue that still blows my mind
or maybe most people don't have an inner
monologue but most people who make
movies and entertainment do and that's
why it's just kind of normal to see it
everywhere I have no idea point is if
I'm pointing out a thing I loved about
this movie that some people might hate
about this movie it might very well be
that it might be that you're hanging out
with someone who's so cold zero [__]
given he's a murderer for hire and not
in that Dexter Morgan kind of way where
it's like well yeah he's a murderer but
he does have the code and although
Dexter doesn't give two moral [__]
about it I can kind of annex his code
into my moral sensibility so it makes it
more palatable what about a high school
teacher turned pathological murdering
meth Kingpin no that's fine no folks die
some worse than others some you're like
you could let that for okay end it being
a David Finch film you see why David
Fincher is in fact the man camera work
is on point the movie looks beautiful in
a world where audio doesn't get enough
love well a lot of creative choices
there too one that stands out in
particular is there's this fight that he
gets into with this one dude had a lot
of low frequency sounds like nothing but
you know when someone takes a hit in a
movie Just snaps you into their POV
because all the high frequency just gets
eliminated
like what the [__] it doesn't commit to
the extreme of all Ambience going out
and admittedly I I like cranking my
subwoofer and my house was rattling so I
thought maybe it was a me thing on my
setting so I watched the scene again and
turned off the subwoofer and still a lot
of low frequency I I don't want to
ramble about audio for this whole video
or anything but I thought it was a
really effective way of just kind of
focusing up and feeling like you're
there with him or you're in his shoes my
point being the devil's in the details
and David Fincher is a master of details
I did feel the end of the movie just
kind of fizzled for me I was like oh I
guess that's it but in a world where
it's not always the destination that's
the important part there is in fact the
journey I thought the journey was an
unexpectedly engaging one and all this
talk about Killer's killing a feel I
should clarify this is not an action
movie don't go into this thinking it's
an action movie he digs up his buried
weapons for the sake of killing people
in the name of Vengeance though this is
not John Wick he follows the clues to
find the people in the name of killing
them but it is not taken it's
deliberately paced otherwise known known
as a slow burn that's what you call it
if you like it if you don't like it it's
called the movie was slow if you like it
deliberately paced Slow Burn but with
Michael fast Bender not only giving a
top-notch performance but also bringing
his Charisma to the table enthralling
you with the process of what it takes to
make a hit and get away with it it's a
dark joyless tale of calculated murder
at the hands of a nihilistic [__] but
by God if I didn't [__] love that I
think the movie's worth checking out God
willing it gets a physical release I
think it's worth watching and worth
buying on VHS tape that's right with
physical media going away and 4K being
the standard buy it on Blu-ray just
seems obsolete so if I'm going to talk
obsolete I'm going all the way back
interestingly enough this movie is
actually based on a graphic novel I just
learned that so now I I want to check
that out all right so the killer have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite David Fincher film
or if you want to go really crazy like
be a legend rank the David Fincher films
that' actually kind of be a tough
ranking but whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and does
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see
[Music]
more